und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka und
olaf schulze geht es wie schon sein
vorgänger man stellt rasch fest dass das
kanzleramt tatsächlich ein gänzlich
anderes ist als alle anderen
joschka fischer nannte es mal die
todeszone der politik von tag eins an
kann es um krieg und frieden gehen
fischer und schröder waren seinerzeit
kaum vereidigt da mussten sie sich schon
damit befassen ob sie erstmals bundes
deutsche soldaten in einem kriegseinsatz
schicken angela merkel hatte etwas mehr
schonfrist bevor bei ihr die
weltfinanzkrise zuschlug und nun scholz
eigentlich hätte das heute in washington
ein antrittsbesuch werden sollen bei dem
man freundlich über transatlantische
gemeinsamkeiten spricht stattdessen ein
krisen besuch und ein kanzler unter
druck wie die reise bis zur stunde
verlief berichtet claudia bates als
der bundeskanzler in washington ankommt
weiß er es gilt einiges klarzustellen
bei diesem besuch in krisenzeiten viele
fragen warten auf ihn hier wie
zuverlässig ist deutschland wirklich
wenn es um sanktionen gegen russland
geht warum die zögerlichkeit bei
nordstream 2 warum keine
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine das hat
vertrauen gekostet
ankunft am weißen haus präsident biden
selbst gab sich immer überzeugt von der
deutschen loyalität und so ist das
wichtigste heute demonstrative
geschlossenheit
um das offensichtliche zu sagen
deutschland ist einer von amerikas
engsten verbündeten wir arbeiten im
gleichschritt um russland von seiner
aggression in europa abzuschrecken
wir sind die engsten verbündeten und
arbeiten intensiv zusammen und das ist
auch nötig um russlands aggression
gegenüber der ukraine zu bekämpfen
heute zu verkünden dass 350 deutsche
soldaten nach litauen geschickt werden
hilft vertrauen wieder herzustellen
denn kritiker werfen scholz schwäche
gegenüber moskau vor entschlossene worte
wurden von ihm heute erwartet wird einen
sehr hohen preis haben wenn es dazu
kommt dass die ukraine militärisch
angegriffen wird und wir bereiten das
auch präzise vor und sind seit langer
zeit dabei die details dazu zu
besprechen denn es geht ja dann darum
schnell zügig und entschlossen zu
handeln und vor allem einheitliche
auch hier in den usa sitzt der
bundeskanzler seine medien offensive
fort erklärt die deutsche position in
der washington post denn die
us-öffentlichkeit und parlamentarier
wollen überzeugt werden dass deutschland
einig und entschieden mit den
verbündeten handeln werde und
unmissverständlich an der seite der
ukraine stehe
scholz und beiden sind sich einig in der
bewertung der bedrohung die der
russische aufmarsch an der grenze zur
ukraine bedeutet einigkeit auch das
abschreckung wesentlich ist und
diplomatie die die ganze woche
weitergehen wird in der hoffnung dass
russland doch noch deeskaliert
und dann schalten wir live nach
washington zu unserem korrespondenten el
mati wir sind immer in diesen minuten
gingen die prämie pressekonferenz von
beiden und scholz los sie haben das
parallel auf dem ohr was hört man
ja der präsident hat natürlich die
pressekonferenz eröffnet und er hat ganz
klar gesagt deutschland sei ein sehr
enger partner es gebe eine enge und
entschlossene kooperation wie er sagte
und der hatte brauchte gebrauchtes kann
angesichts der aggression durch russland
eben kein business as usual geben ob das
irgendwas mit nord stream zwei der
gaspipeline zu tun hat das wissen wir
noch nicht vielleicht kommt man den
fragen noch mal drauf und er hat aber
noch einmal klar gemacht usa sehen in
deutschland einen verlässlichen partner
auf den man sich verlassen kann und
umgekehrt olaf scholz hat jetzt gerade
sein statement begonnen und er hat ganz
klar gesagt dass es wichtig ist dass man
gewalt gemeinsam das gleiche sagt aber
auch gleich handelt also er hat ähnlich
wie der us-präsident klar gemacht das
ist sehr sehr ernst zu sanktionen geben
wird aber bisher ist von dem stichwort
nord stream 2 noch nicht die rede
gewesen dass man sich da wechselseitig
um zuverlässigkeit
attestieren muss es spricht ja auch
benders hatte massive kritik an der
deutschen außenpolitik im vorfeld den
usa gegeben wie wird scholz jetzt
versuchen solche zweifel an der
zuverlässigkeit zu zerstreuen
ja das versucht der wilde einmal
klarmachen wie viel deutschland schon in
den vergangenen jahren für die ukraine
getan hat und dass man natürlich auch
durch die 350 soldaten
bundeswehrsoldaten jetzt nochmal nach
litauen entsendet werden zusätzlich die
ostflanke der nato stärken will aber
hier stellt man natürlich besonders die
frage nach nord stream 2 ist deutschland
bereit im falle des falles dann klar
tatsächlich nach dem 2 zu beerdigen ich
sag das mal so salopp bisher hat der
kanzler immer gesagt man hat alle
optionen auf dem tisch aber die
amerikaner wollen mehr sie wollen dass
ein klares wort gesprochen wird weil nur
so die abschreckung gegenüber wladimir
putin das ist hier die haltung
funktionieren kann während der kanzlei
ja die worte benutzt von einer
strategischen ich sag mal
uneindeutigkeit so hat er es formuliert
heute in einem zeitungs interview mit
der washington post und das hängt hier
so ein bisschen in der luft man
schüttelt er den kopf in so einer
situation kann man nicht uneindeutigkeit
projizieren sondern die amerikaner sind
der meinung klare kante gegenüber
ermöglichen invasion in die ukraine zu
dieser klaren kante gehört ja auch die
forderung nach waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine also die 350 soldaten bundeswehr
soldaten die jetzt vorzeitig früher als
sowieso schon geplant nach litauen zu
dem bataillon dort geschickt werden die
sind ja eigentlich nicht das was die
amerikaner sich erwartet haben oder
reicht das schon als als morgengabe
jetzt sozusagen bei dieser reise
ja ich glaube dem weißen haus reicht das
zunächst mal aus weil man weiß genau
wenn es zu sanktionen käme dann wäre
deutschland mit am härtesten davon
betroffen und würde die last vor allen
dingen tragen müssen aber hier im
amerikanischen kongress beispielsweise
ist man der festen überzeugung
deutschland müsste auch
waffenlieferungen eu keine unterstützen
können man fragt sich hier so ein
bisschen ein land das im vergangenen
jahr über 9 milliarden
euro an rüstungsgüter in alle welt
exportiert hat unter anderem auch in ein
land wie ergibt und warum dieses land in
der lage ist auch ukraine deutlicher mit
waffen zu unterstützen
die historischen gründe die ins feld
geführt werden dafür hat man hier in
washington nicht so viel verständnis
weil man sagt gerade die lehren aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg sind ja die dass man
die freiheit gegen die aggression und
gegen den autoritär ismus verteidigen
müssen dankeschön erstmal einmal bis
sehen und wenn während der
pressekonferenz die jetzt ja parallel
läuft noch entscheidendes neues gesagt
wird dann liefern wir dass während der
sendung noch nacht dank erstmal nachbar
schicken
während sich der deutsche kanzler in
washington also bemüht den eindruck
eines unsicheren kantonisten auszuräumen
ist seine außenministerin erneut in kiew
und der französische präsident in moskau
eines hat wladimir putin also schon mal
erreicht alle welt redet über und mit
ihm axel sturm berichtet
heute ist ein guter tag um krieg zu
verhindern schrieb ein kolumnist am
morgen russische kampfjets über belarus
russischen raketensysteme die militärs
halten die drohkulisse aufrecht eine
kulisse aber ist noch kein krieg und
deshalb sieht die deutsche
aussenministerin raum für diplomatie
auch wenn sie schon bei der ankunft in
kiew gewusst haben dürfte dieser besuch
wird schwieriger als der letzte vor drei
wochen deutschland soll liefern waffen
sagen sie hier die antihaltung in berlin
sorgt für unverständnis in kiew
mit hinblick auf die ukraine halten wir
diese haltung für unfair wir glauben
dass deutschland mehr handlungsspielraum
hat es dürfte diplomatisch zumindest
exotisch sein ein treffen unter freunden
vorab mit forderungen zu versehen wie
annalena baerbock amtskollege das heute
tat ein feldlazarett helme aus
deutschland das alles wird hier zwar
goutiert gewünscht aber wird mehr stehen
ohne wenn und aber zur territorialen
integrität
und souveränität der ukraine und diese
solidarität will ich mit meinem besuch
heute hier noch einmal unterstreichen
und ganz deutlich zum ausdruck bringen
dass wir alles dafür tun werden dass es
zu keiner weiteren eskalation kommen
wird wir haben deswegen eine reihe von
harten maßnahmen gemeinsam gegenüber
russland für diesen fall vorbereitet
waffen wohl keine zusagen über waffen
aber mehr als symbolische solidarität
auch hier an der gedenkstätte für die
opfer der großen hungersnot die stalin
in den 30er jahren über die ukraine
gebracht hatte beistand reicht das
auftritt missio präsident moskau jung
wie geht's rein
hattest du eine angenehme reise sehr gut
makro war optimistisch für seinen besuch
bei putin man respektiert sich heißt es
ich denke dass die heutige diskussion
eine richtung vorgeben kann eine in die
wir gehen müssen deeskalation
ich möchte dir dafür danken dass sich
frankreich aktiv an der suche nach
grundsätzlichen lösungen für die
probleme beteiligt
man duzt sich ob das reicht wieder ein
tag vor bei einer an dem der krieg
vielleicht verhindert wurde oder doch
näher gerückt ist deutschlands
chefdiplomaten jedenfalls fährt morgen
in die ost ukraine an die kontakt linie
wo krieg seit 2014 zum alltag gehört
bei den diplomatischen tanz den die
bundesregierung in der russland frage
vollführt mit bio retten rundum nord
stream 2 steht natürlich ein elefant im
raum die abhängigkeit der europäer im
allgemeinen und deutschlands im
besonderen vom russischen erdgas laut
eu-kommission kommen derzeit rund 40
prozent der gas einfuhren aus russland
für deutschland sind es sogar über 50
prozent
gaspreise sind bereits spürbar gestiegen
auch wer nicht in gas beheizten gebäuden
wohnt bekommt das zu spüren der
preisanstieg verteuert auch viele
industrieproduktion was heißt wären die
folgen wenn moskau den gashahn zudreht
frieren für kiew da könnte man nicht
solidarität bröckeln allerdings sind die
abhängigkeiten nicht einseitig erläutert
floh er neu an
die flamme brennt noch mehr aber auch
nicht neben niedersachsen theoretisch
wäre das hier deutschlands größter
speicher für erdgas betrieben von der
russischen staatsfirma gazprom praktisch
aber wird hier im moment fast kein gas
gespeichert der füllstand knapp unter 4
prozent so niedrig dass sie jetzt auch
in brüssel unruhig werden das sehen wir
schon seit einigen monaten dass russland
gas als druckmittel einsetzt wir sehen
es in der ukraine wir haben es in
moldova gesehen wir merken es an den
niedrigen ständen hier bei uns jedes
gewöhnlich unternehmen sagen sie in
brüssel würde bei diesem preisanstieg
schnell mehr gas liefern mehr geld
verdienen doch gastraum hier die
firmenzentrale in sankt petersburg ist
kein gewöhnliches unternehmen sondern
der verlängerte arm des kreml was europa
eigentlich längst weiß schon 2014 nach
der krim krise wollte man die
abhängigkeit von russischem gas endlich
reduzieren nicht nur angela merkel
versprach damals das ist eine durchaus
neue betrachtung der gesamten energie
politik ergeben wird wenn man sich die
zahlen anguckt dann hat sich da nichts
bewegt sondern im gegenteil unsere
importabhängigkeit ist gewachsen was
wenn europas wichtigster gaslieferant
jetzt noch weniger gas liefert hektisch
versucht europa alternativen aufzutun
die eu energiekommissar am freitag in
aserbaidschan europa bittet um mehr gas
egal wie fragwürdig das regime sein mag
vielleicht auch deshalb erwähnt die
kommissionspräsidentin öffentlich lieber
andere partner in der kurzfrist sprechen
wir jetzt mit allen anderen anbietern
für gas weltweit ganz vorne weg die
vereinigten staaten von amerika die usa
bieten an wieder uneigennützig noch
günstig europa mehr flüssiggas
sogenanntes lng zu liefern die nötigen
terminals immerhin hat europa massiv
ausgebaut wie hier in rotterdam das
langfristig wirksamste mittel sich
unabhängig von russischem gas zu machen
aber steht direkt daneben erneuerbare
energie es ist vor allem diese strategie
die dem kreml missfällt sagen kenner
russlands
sie wenn die empfänger von russischem
gas egal wo plötzlich entscheiden dass
sie so eine art green deal machen dann
ist das eine herausforderung eine
bedrohung ein risiko für russland
europa ist abhängig von russischem gas
aber russland eben auch davon abhängig
dass europa weiter abhängig bleibt
und wir schalten nochmal nach washington
ein soeben haben sich beiden und stolz
tatsächlich zum thema nord stream 2
geäußert
der amerikanische präsident hat sich
kristallklar festgelegt er hat gesagt
wenn russland einmarschiert in die
ukraine dann wird es kein nord stream 2
geben punkt danach wurde natürlich auch
der bundeskanzler gefragt aber er hat
trotz mehrfacher nachfragen das wort
nord stream 2 weiterhin vermieden er hat
gesagt wenn es dazu kommt dann werde man
mit den verbündeten gemeinsam und einig
handeln jetzt kann man das so lesen dass
er damit schon mit einschließt dass man
dort zwei dann aufgeben würde auf die
wiederholten nachfragen der reporter hat
der amerikanische präsident dann noch
einmal auf den punkt gebracht wir haben
komplettes oder vollstes vertrauen in
deutschland in die bundesregierung und
wir haben keine zweifel das ist
jedenfalls dass mit dem urlaub stolz
nach hause fahren wird das wird noch
interessant werden danke schon einmal
für diese aktuelle informationen aus
washington und jetzt macht hier erstmal
hans wolff weiter mit anderen meldungen
des tages nach den todesschüssen auf
zwei junge polizeibeamte vor einer woche
in rheinland pfalz findet sich im
internet viel beileid aber auch hass und
hetze davon seien 102 beiträge nach
vorläufigem stand strafrechtlich
relevant sagt anna britische
innenminister lebe das insgesamt hat
eine besondere ermittlungsgruppe bislang
im internet fast 400 fälle von hass und
hetze im zusammenhang mit der tat
festgestellt
der neu gewählte bundesvorstand der cdu
hat eine programm und
grundsatzkommission eingesetzt den
vorsitz übernimmt parteivize carsten
linnemann die kommission soll bis zur
europawahl im frühjahr 2024 die
inhaltlichen grundlagen der cdu politik
für die zukunft beschreiben wie die
partei mitteilte unter dem dach der
kommission sollen elf fachkommissionen
positionen zu wichtigen themen
erarbeiten
nach mehr als einer woche von protesten
und lkw blockaden in der kanadischen
hauptstadt ottawa hat deren
bürgermeister den notstand ausgerufen
und hilfe von der regierung gefordert
tausende demonstranten waren am
wochenende erneut nach ottawa gekommen
mit lastwagen und traktoren blockierten
sie die innenstadt nahe des parlaments
auslöser der proteste waren im januar
eingeführte im vorschriften für lkw
fahrer inzwischen richten sich die
demonstrationen allgemein gegen die
korona maßnahmen und gegen die regierung
von premierminister trikot
knapp zwei jahre nach der korona
bedingten schließung öffnet australien
ab dem 21 februar seine grenzen für den
internationalen reiseverkehr
voraussetzung für die einreise sei eine
vollständige grundimmunisierung nicht
jedoch eine booster impfung erklärte
premierminister scott morrison im zuge
einer null kowitz strategie hatte
australien seine außengrenzen im märz
2020 weitgehend geschlossen und erst
seit dezember letzten jahres
schrittweise wieder geöffnet in israel
ist die zahl der schwererkrankten corona
patienten auf einem rack auto dennoch
wird die pflicht zum sogenannten grünen
passt weitgehend abgeschafft der impf
und genesungs nachweis muss seit heute
nur noch in hochrisiko bereichen wie
pflegeheimen und bei großveranstaltungen
vorgezeigt werden weite teile des
öffentlichen lebens zu etwa restaurants
und kinos können nun auch ohne den pass
und ohne negativen corona test besucht
werden
und wie geht es in deutschland weiter
mit corona wie immer uneinheitlich da
bleiben wir uns für deren treue die
einen wollen mehr lockern die anderen
noch nicht und bayerns ministerpräsident
müller überrascht mit der ankündigung
die ab mitte märz geltende impfpflicht
für pflegekräfte vorerst lieber doch
nicht umzusetzen
das erstaunt insofern als sünder lange
zeit gewissermaßen kapitän im team
vorsicht sich stark machte für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht und im bundesrat
auch der teil impfpflicht für
gesundheits und pflegeberufe zustimmte
und jetzt fährt bayern plötzlich aus
obwohl die impfquote dort
vergleichsweise niedrig ist was
dahintersteckt haben wir unseren bayern
korrespondenten alexander pohl gefragt
opposition ist mist so viel steht fest
für markus söder aber er scheint
entschlossen aus diesem ist in berlin
politisch kapital zu schlagen für sich
und seine csu in bayern söder ist nach
seinem selbstverständnis nicht irgendein
oppositionspolitiker der union sondern
der der den takt vorgibt leider ist es
so manchmal muss man auch sagen wir auch
dinge entscheiden damit auch andere
lösungen und kompromisse möglich sind so
als könne er nicht anders der politische
positionswechsel ist dem csu-chef nicht
fremd vor allem wenn ihm die umfragen
sowie der zeit diesen wechsel nahelegen
vor den landtagswahlen im kommenden jahr
muss söder den spagat meistern vor
pressure und zuhörer zu sein will er die
csu in bayern an der regierung halten
und so verwirft der csu-chef heute die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht der
nicht nur er sondern auch fast alle csu
bundestagsabgeordneten zu hatten die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht die
zum 15 dritten kommen soll ist kein
wirksames mittel mehr um die jetzige
omikron welle zu begleiten oder zu
dämpfen oder zu stoppen sie kann aber
leider ein instrument sein um die
belastungssituation und pflegesituation
deutlich zu verschlechtern die sorge
dass viele pflegekräfte ihren beruf den
rücken kehren wird in der union geteilt
sodass kurs trifft im jahr der
landtagswahlen einen nerv während der
bundesgesundheitsminister vor allzu
schnellen lockerungen warnt tun hessen
und schleswig-holstein genau das und
beenden die 2g regel im einzelhandel
cdu-chef märz fordert zwar einen
abgestimmten fahrplan
aber wieso will auch er von der
einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
erstmal nichts wissen wir sind zu dem
übereinstimmenden ergebnis gekommen so
wie auch unsere freunde in bayern im csu
parteivorstand heute morgen dass wir die
bundesregierung auffordern den vollzug
der einrichtungs bezogenen impfpflicht
auszusetzen nein sagen dazu die grünen
es gehe um den schutz jener menschen die
wegen ihres alters oder bestimmte
vorerkrankungen besonders gefährdet
seien
dieser schutz ist nach wie vor unser
ziel es ist nach wie vor ein anliegen
dass wir ganz klar haben das heißt wir
werden uns dafür einsetzen dass die
einrichtungs bezogen impfpflicht
bundesweit pünktlich umgesetzt wird das
heißt zum 15 märz mag muss nun wieder
könnte das in seiner neu gefundenen
oppositionsrolle durchaus nützen dieses
mal wird die union die seitenhiebe aus
bayern zu schätzen wissen
das risiko sich anzustecken bleibt
aktuell jedenfalls so hoch wie noch nie
die sieben tage incidents erreicht wird
1426 einen neuen höchststand die
absolute zahl der gemeldeten
neuinfektionen ist wie immer nach dem
wochenende nicht so hoch wie an anderen
wochentagen 95
1267 im vergleich zum montag letzter
woche ist auch das aber wieder ein
anstieg
und weiterhin sind kitas und schulen
besonders betroffen auf diese weise
versuchen dann auch viele kinder einen
regulären unterricht und viele die in
den schulräumen sitzen fühlen sich
unsicher wendigen berichtet aus hamburg
eine stunde am tag ist studienzeit an
diesem hamburger gymnasium gemeinsames
arbeiten wir an der uni lange zeit ging
das nicht inzwischen lässt schule diesen
er wieder zu den konzerten aber heißt
das die meisten hier werben sich
infizieren
es ist zumindest eine teilweise
durchseuchung wir sind auf jeden fall im
niedrigen einstelligen prozentbereich
das heißt wir werden in wenigen wochen
ein gut stück der kinder wirklich
infiziert haben die alternative zur
durchseuchung während schulschließungen
auch die angst vor spätfolgen wie long
kubik spielt eine rolle
und fragt sich auch selber als schüler
wäre es jetzt sinnvoll wenn sie doch
geschlossen wer so ein fan von präsenz
dass freunde sehen kann man kann sich
mit besser beteiligen sie hatten jetzt
auch ein paar kroner fälle in unserer
klasse aber es war halt ganz normal
weiter unterricht die waren in
quarantäne zu hause wie wichtig ganz
normaler unterricht ist zeigt das
beispiel einer anderen schule sie liegt
in einem sozialen brennpunkt die eltern
hier sind oft überfordert auch mit
bürokratie die schule hat deshalb ein
eigenes pcr-test zentrum und kümmert
sich um quarantäne und isolation jede
generelle einschränkung des
regelbetriebs hier wäre folgenschwer
wenn man dann bemerken dass wir hohen
anteil von kindeswohlgefährdung platz in
familien haben weil der stress auf
familien extrem zugenommen hat wenn wir
feststellen dass eben doch ganz schöne
lern rückstände
dazu gekommen sind wo ich sagen bitte
alles an richtig ausschließen aber
schulen müssen offenbar ein wunsch bei
incidence 5000 an hamburgs schulen die
schüler wissen was auf dem spiel steht
und spielen mit
alle mühe dass wir uns nicht anstecken
machen da auch irgendwie alle
vorsichtsmaßnahmen aber wenn es passiert
dann passiert ich habe sehr viel passt
von der schule
und konnte auch nichts nach
die jüngste bevölkerungsgruppe muss die
meisten regeln einhalten auch um die
älteren nicht anzustecken ein
spannungsfeld das auch in den schulen
immer mehr ankommt die freude ist for
future bewegung hat den jungen gezeigt
dass sie auch bei den älteren einiges
bewegen können
von ihr über 50-jährigen dort denkt euer
körper mein körper gehört mir ich
bestimme selbst nämlich der staat darf
hier nicht reinreden müssen wir hier in
der schule die ganzen einschränkungen in
kauf nehmen müssen mit der unsicherheit
leben und und und
spannendes thema und ich glaube dass das
wäre ein generationenkonflikt der gut
täte
einblicke in das seelenleben der
jüngsten gewährt derzeit diese
grundschule die kinder sollten auf
masken schreiben was sie über corona
denken die aufarbeitung dieser gedanken
eine gesellschaftliche aufgabe für alle
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit dem blick
auf die wirtschaft das thema inflation
ist der zu beginn des neuen jahres
erhalten geblieben und dazu passt eine
neue umfrage des ifo-instituts welche
erwartungen die unternehmen haben wie es
mit ihren preisen weitergeht weil real
in welche richtung geht es mit den
preisen weiter rauf das ifo-institut hat
9000 unternehmen gefragt wie sie ihre
preise in den kommenden drei monaten
gestalt mir und fast die hälfte will sie
anheben in erster linie liegt das an den
gestiegenen kosten für energie und
vorprodukte ja und diese kosten die
geben viele unternehmen an ihre kunden
daneben weiter das ifo-institut hebt
deswegen auch seine inflationsprognose
an von 3,3 auf jetzt 4 prozent die
preiserhöhungen betreffen alle
wirtschaftszweige darunter einzelhandel
industrie und dienstleister unterm
strich wollen laut ifo so viele
unternehmen ihre preise anheben wie
niemals zuvor aber all das nur unter dem
vorbehalt dass die energie nicht
abermals teurer wird sonst könnte es in
sachen preise eine noch größere
überraschung geben beim kaffee ist die
inflation schon angekommen weil die
ernte in brasilien und anderen kaffee
ländern schlecht war dazu ist die fracht
teurer geworden tchibo reagiert darauf
mit deutlichen preisanhebungen je nach
sorte soll das pfund kaffee um 50 cent
bis 1 euro 30 teurer seien vermutlich
nur eine frage der zeit bis andere
nachziehenden tchibo gilt als gradmesser
in der branche auch die europäische
zentralbank hat sich heute noch mal zum
thema inflation geäußert ezb chefin
lagarde hat wieder betont dass sie die
hohe inflation für kein dauerzustand
hält eine zinserhöhung noch dieses jahr
die schließt sie aber auch nicht mehr
aus
vielen dank
eine meldung vom fußball nationalspieler
niklas süle wechselt vom fc bayern
münchen zu borussia dortmund ab
kommender saison wird der 26 jährige
innenverteidiger für den bvb spielen
wechselt ablösefrei vom rekordmeister
und erhält in dortmund einen vertrag
über vier jahre bis 2026
der tropische wirbelsturm hat auf der
insel madagaskar schwere schäden
verursacht mindestens 20 menschen
starben
55.000 wurden vorübergehend obdachlos
mit bis zu 235 kilometern pro stunde
fegte der zyklone der nacht zum sonntag
über die vor der ostküste afrikas
gelegene insel tausende häuser stehen
unter wasser oder wurden komplett
zerstört
bereits ende januar hatte ein
tropensturm große zerstörungen in dem
äußerst armen staat angerichtet
das war für uns an diesem montagabend um
0 uhr meldet sich danach sein götti mir
mit unserem heutigen update und ihr
beide melden uns morgen wieder
[Musik]
guten abend in den vergangenen tagen
zeigte sich das winterwetter von seiner
gefährlichen seite es gab viel regen es
gab schnee es gab sturm orkan und
gewitter in den alpen gab es tote und
verletzte bei schneebrettlawinen durch
triebschnee sehr viel hat es jetzt in
kurzer zeit bei sturm geschneit auf den
wind abgewandten seite der bergkämme
sammelt sich schnee an dieser schnee
bildet eine fest verbundene schicht weil
sich die schneekristalle in diesen neu
schneewolken verhaken diese schicht
auserwählte neuschnee geht so gut wie
keine verbindung ein mit dem teils
verharschten altschnee untendrunter so
lösen sich schneebrettlawinen manchmal
sogar spontan und auch bei einer
lawinenwarnstufe von 3 sollten sie also
von touren jenseits der gesicherten
pisten absehen auch heute nacht fällt
noch schnee hier in ostbayern und auch
im thüringer wald sonst ist es häufig
bedeckt und es fällt ein wenig regen die
temperaturen sinken auf plus fünf bis
minus sieben grad und liegen morgen über
tag dann zwischen plus 4 und 12 grad das
wetter ist im wesentlichen zweigeteilt
im norden ist es meist bedeckt und
nordöstlich von weser und elbe fällt
noch etwas regen im süden ist es
freundlicher besonders am oberrhein in
den nächsten tagen bleibt es mild im
süden ist es sonnig im norden eher
verregnet und am freitag wird es markant
kälter guten abend